it's time for roses and roses I am so
mad I am so mad I am I am mad I'm mad
I'm angry hi everyone i'm lauren zima
and thank you for watching roses and
Rose day as we go over the season finale
of re lyin dykes season of The Bachelor
let's start with some direct quotes
shall we shall we shall we shall we
quotes are each Abeka the more I hung
out with you the more I felt like I was
losing the possibility of maybe
reconciling things were born I just
helped the further along we got the
further I started drifting away from the
possibility of trying it again with her
in the words of Becca Arie that is a
normal relationship
you guys okay we were promised the most
shocking season finale ever on The
Bachelor and I think it delivered I mean
this show's been on for more than 20
seasons so we've had quite a lot of
moments and actually Oh shameless plug
up and EZLN can we rank the most
shopping finales in The Bachelor ever so
we've had one Pablo we've had Jason
Mesnick now we have Ari after a season
that people critiqued as boring this
finale certainly sent things out with a
bang because this franchise doesn't
disappoint that's why I love it so much
but very controversial here's the thing
it was three hours long right right yeah
so we're just gonna speed through the
beginning basically what happened was
that Ari and Becca and Lauren and arias
family all were now in Peru and Arie
said the Becca was the safe option and
that really gives me a lot of comfort
and that Lauren was riskier and he needs
a lot of reassurance but he also has to
reach her lauren so who needs more
reassurance and Ari's family said the
Becca seems like the best way to go
because she was solid and in the words
of always dad he needs a good kick in
the ass kicking the ash what does that
say about Arie so Becca is an apple or
starfish or Lauren's the starfish at the
Apple either way somebody's a starfish
somebody's an apple and Arie dumped
Lauren okay that's what happens now
let's cut to the chase I have love that
you broke down those walls you know
so Arie breaks up with Morin and true to
form Lauren is borderline silent as he
breaks up with her but I have to say
that when she got in the limo this was
the most I've ever agreed with things
that Lauren had to say ari told her that
he didn't really know what he was gonna
do until the morning of the morning of
imagine if this was normal life and
somebody told you that they were gonna
propose to someone later but they
weren't sure who yet they were deciding
between two people
now I know that it's a reality show but
still I spoke to gold standard bachelor
simply the bands bent Higgins about this
and he says that he doesn't think our I
should have proposed it all being that
torn that interview and more with Ben is
uppity Tammy calm because you know what
through all of this muck we've got to
have a little light keeping us going
shining us through and we're not done
yet and that are a completely blindsided
her drink every time somebody was
blindsided on this episode and I choose
you today but I choose you every day
from here on out if we spend time going
back through this episode you guys and
looking at all of the ironic quotes I
mean Becca told Ahri's mother I've never
doubted him and his integrity then we
get little glimpses of what Ari and
Becca's life has been like in these
secret meet ups that every couple does
after the show finishes tapings so they
can stay together and be happy until
they can be revealed but as we know that
will not be the case for them this
finale brought us many new things the
first time we've seen unedited footage
on the franchise and even a new phrase
the most emotional scene ever
so Ari's been saying that he goes to bed
thinking about Lauren and he wakes up
thinking about Lauren and so he knows
he's got to break up with Becca and what
he does is he shows up to see Becca at
this Los Angeles home and Becca can
instantly tell something's wrong
everybody nervous and then we kind of
see the camera guys walk in and Ari
looks at them like I don't know if he's
looking at them because it's weird or
because he's like waiting for them to
all come in and then he says we have to
talk
very quickly we got a split screen yes
because this is going to be unedited
footage now guys this is controversial
should the breakup have been filmed
here's where I land on it Ari and Becca
both signed up to be on a reality show
about their love lives
so as painful as this was to watch and
it's terrible I'm on board with filming
it you've got to show the whole story
the true story and we got maybe the
truest story we've ever seen on The
Bachelor because they showed it i netted
it we saw cameras in the background we
got the split screen very reminiscent of
Rosie O'Donnell and Elisabeth Hasselbeck
on the view wasn't anyone else thinking
about yes so Ari says all these
wonderful things and Becca says are you
effing kidding me about 25 times drink
every time she says that you go girl
and they're at this beautiful house and
we can hear some kind of water feature
in the background constantly throughout
this breakup I still have a few
questions after all this was this when
you hug her we know that Becca knows
that Ari had a conversation with
Lawrence and our even says but he feels
he's been pretty upfront with her and I
don't think that that's true
I think Ari maybe thinks that that's
true because he seemed to say that you
know Becca knows he's been thinking
about Lauren but I would venture to
guess that Ari told Becca look I still
have some feelings with Lauren for
Lauren because I broke up with her not
that long ago and Becca was actually
being super gracious and trying to help
him work through those feelings even by
saying have a conversation with Lauren
well we know how that turned out by the
way guys a little inside info on the
timeline I do know from a source that
Ari called Lauren on the night of the
premiere let me broke up with Bek only a
few weeks later so yeah Becca has to
explain to 36 year old Ari what a normal
relationship is but when you're in a
relationship with someone you have to
let go of the possibilities of being
really in relationships with other
people that's what should have been
happening as we remember Ari's on father
said they do something
a bit of a kick in the ass so bakit
tells re you shouldn't know one knee
mm-hmm and then she starts to cry and
it's really emotional and raw and
terrible to watch and re at one point
goes and knocks on the door to see if
she's okay hey are you okay in that dad
like way as if somebody's I don't know
kind of nauseous inside the room she's
not okay re you just broke up with her
out of nowhere
blindsiding her she thought that she was
spending the rest of her life with you
she's not okay and it's okay that she's
not okay okay from here on we commence
with should I stay or should I go the
answer is you should go re but he's
still gonna ask BEC a bunch more times
like do you want me to go and she's like
no but are you okay and she's like and I
love how Becca shuts this now please
just go good god Ari just go just go
just go obviously back here live now in
studio with Becca and then we get one
sentence from Becca at the end and she
tells Chris Harrison that it was all
just brutal to watch back I kind of
blacked out and that she has a lot of
questions for Ari I'm alive after the
final rose
though she doesn't know how truthful the
answers will be yes Queen mm-hmm Becca
kufran for Bachelorette
man that's cold just like re during this
breakup so you guys what did you think
were you shocked that Becca was the one
that re broke up with were you blown
away by the way that it happened do you
think that it should have been on camera
or not and ultimately what questions do
you still have for re on a fr mmm thank
you everybody so much for watching
I'm truly distraught and here's why I
want Becca to be the Bachelorette you
guys which we will find out who the
Bachelorette is on after the final rose
this cannot be Becca story Becca cannot
be the person we're when she goes to a
grocery store in six months somebody
comes up to her and says Oh weren't you
on The Bachelor were you that girl who
got dumped on The Bachelor for the other
girl no this isn't your story Becca she
asked Arie if she did anything wrong and
she didn't and I don't want to hear a
woman ask that question on this show
again if you are asking if you did
something wrong you probably did it
Arie did something wrong here Arie did
and I hope that he owns up to it on AFR
but we will see until then you guys
thank you so much for being with me all
season long this has been quite an
amazing journey oh my god it was crazy
wow I love that you know hmm in the
words of Arie have a good night
everybody I love you guys for real
everyday and I choose you every day and
I back down
bye
chasey just go would you just go why are
you still here just go why you still
here would you would you just go
should I go just go